so listen I got a bunch of questions
you've been asked a lot of stuff about
Rebel Moon I like throwing some curve
balls at the beginning besides Rebel
Moon if someone has never seen anything
you've done before what is the first
thing you'd like them watching and why o
probably sent them a dance video of mine
from a million years ago that's totally
but movie wise I think I'd
say I'd say maybe
climax sure for for various reasons I'd
say maybe Atomic blonde I would say ill
manners which was my debut the first
film I ever made shot it with my my
friends in London in my
community first time I ever acted in my
life and um meant a lot to me um and
still means a lot to me in terms of like
showing my my my community and my area
and all my friends are in it so yeah it
all mans what is the most nervous you've
been
the the night before the first day of
filming and it could be this project but
like literally like you know you're
about to go to set the next day and
you're like oh F I'd say Deadpool I was
like I was really nervous because I love
I've been reading Deadpool since I was
like 10 years old you know I used to go
to the Comic Book Fairs and collect them
I still got my my comics from back in
the day so I was like really nervous cuz
I really wanted to do well and um I
think Tim would say the same thing that
like the first day I turned up a bit
nervous and I remember him like we joke
about it now but like he came to me
after like 2 weeks and was like and was
like I want to let you know like you are
enough and like I want you to be you and
I want you to just like be how you are
when we're just talking messing around
and like that he really filled me with
confidence and kind
of made me able to break through that
kind of impostor syndrome and um and
then after that I really did my best
work and some of my favorite scenes in
it were even when I came came back to
Vancouver like 6 months or a year later
for the re-shoot and it was like I was
just super confident loved all of the
crew loved him and um and could hit the
ground running but yeah that first day I
was bricking it for me it was definitely
this project the first I mean I'm I'm
nervous before each first day of every
production that I've been on and even as
a dancer but I I think it's just a
testimony of like just caring and I
think for this project because of the
the scale of it the size of it and
nailing Kora and and and and you know to
feel like I'm
starting you know from a good place and
of understanding the character which you
you keep finding about the character
constantly anyway but I think yeah this
one was um was pretty was pretty n
wracking so uh individual question for
both of you with this project you you
play a character that basically is the
the the badass when you walk in the room
you can kick everyone's ass and you need
to make the audience believe it
so what is it like preparing for a role
like that where you need to really
believe that you are that person and for
you you are playing like a real villain
and you need to sort of when you walk in
the audience needs to fear you so what
are you doing before you're stepping on
set and during filming that makes it so
you command that presence when you are
on screen and in the room I feel like
for Kora the the challenge was also and
what was I think for me as an actor
interest saying is that I she didn't
come from a place of wanting to be a
badass from wanting to to to be that
person anymore she used to be a soldier
she used to do things that she highly
regrets and and and and holds with
herself in um in a pretty dark place and
she she refuses to fight that's what she
says at the beginning she's trying to to
run away basically but I so it was
interesting for me to play that color of
like being the badass but that refu that
doesn't want any of of that so um but in
order to do that I think for me it was
just conditioning my soul with all of
those colors basically but no basically
putting in me that all the training that
I have had being like younger from such
a young age uh for to be a soldier and
to be this this person she has put
behind her a long time
ago yeah for me you know to be able to
you said to be able to command that kind
of fear and such this definitely wasn't
a direct intention of mine in in in that
regard you know for me it's about me
understanding what the emotional state
of being of the character in that scene
is and if I've got that I'm super
confident and if I'm super confident I
shall command that respect you know plus
like I got a spaceship behind me I've
got an army I got priests I'm wearing
like you know tailored stuff stepping
onto a Dusty Village you know you feel
this way knee high leather boots you
know
kinky um but like you feel you
feel that way and it's and it's like you
know you know that when you step into a
movie that the costume Department the
makeup department and then after that
like Tom hulkenberg junky XL is going to
make you know accentuate the emotion so
they're going to help you so much really
what you need to be is like secure and
confident in your emotional state of
being for that scene so it's kind of
like it's the same if I'm prepar ing to
be you know a washed up pop star or a
East London drug dealer whatever it is
it's like understand what the emotional
requirement of the scene is and then
just step in there step in there with
confidence and um that's the thing cor
doesn't think that she she's not
confident that they can win this at all
and um but yeah after that I think it's
just the cause that I'm defending in the
film defending the the less the less
equipped the ones that needed the most
and the cause like from the F the first
scene that is very important to that
keeps happening to people and women in
general so besides Rubble Moon I I'm a
big fan of of Zack Snyder and his films
his filmography what's the film that you
think if if someone has never seen a
Zack Snider movie what's the film they
should start with
Watchman face cut 100 100% it's the
greatest man it's the greatest like it
it changed the game I remember when it
came out and I don't know it was like 20
years ago now uh I don't was 20 but it's
I'm going to say it's
10 12 I don't remember I feel like more
than that I want to say 2010 20 oh 20 it
might have been 08 or something but yeah
I don't remember I apologize either way
like 15 years or something I really like
Alan Moore and have I have I have this
this book at home that I've had for a
long time called Lost Girls have you
ever seen it anyway but I've like I just
started with such a such a good take on
on on Watchman basically Mo British
British Legend one of the greatest why
are there so many good comic book
writers from England man gr it's the
water the weather do you think no but
you know what's interesting is like I I
saw some someone talking about parallels
with like Grant Morrison and gaimon and
uh more and all these people that so
many of them grew up in like were
informed so much by thatches Britain and
how oppressive it was and also so many
of them grew up near power stations and
nuclear power stations and had this idea
of like the that um and the backdrop of
sorry the Cold War whereas like the
world could end so they had these
apocalyptic ideas mixed with this
post-war British sensibilities it's like
a really interesting notion I'm just
about out of time so I want to ask real
fast for both of you what is a scene in
both part one and part two that you
cannot wait for audiences to see I said
that before for me I mean I just have
such a just such dreamy and Powerful
feel from the very last scene between uh
belisarius and Noble and because because
I've had it in my trailer I had the
photo that Zach Drew in my trailer for
the longest time I had like photos I
mean images from so many different
scenes but this one was very there's
something special about it because it
takes place on a on a frozen lake and
the koifish underneath it and just just
the color the the grading of this whole
scene and what it is about and what it
says I I think that I mean I just I
Remember Loving that scene couldn't wait
to see it and when I saw it it really I
mean it marked me and from movie number
two you know
I that's the thing you know I I a part
of me forgets what happens I think in
number two because I haven't seen it yet
we haven't seen it yet we haven't seen
it but my answer for number two was
going to be I don't want to give it away
noil well we know that there's you can
assume there's going to be more action
yeah and and there's is like you know me
and sopia got to to to to do some some
dancing as such in number two and like
I'm really excited I'm really excited
for that but also the buildup to that
there's many little dances happening
let's say which I'm like super hyped
about there is I mean I think I mean
that's in um more sentimental way but
there is a scene in movie number two
where we're all gathered before the
final fight and and the core of the of
the army which is the rebels get
together and share something very
personal about themselves and I remember
shooting that scene and how everybody
poured their heart and soul into into
that moment and I and I I haven't seen
it but I can't wait to see this moment I
feel like it's going to carry movie
number two on a deeper level and join
everybody together but also make people
understand everyone and um and hopefully
sort of I don't know it I think it it it
joins everything that scene that's how I
saw it when I worked on it so I I can't
wait to see it I look forward to I
remember reading that scene in the
screenplay and being like damn this is
deep this is going to be an amazing one
to shoot kind of like an actor's dream
to be H his conversational piece it
makes you care so much about what
unfolds after and yeah I remember when
you guys were shooting it and I
obviously wasn't in that day and I
remember thinking this is this I hope it
goes well for them I hope they enjoy it
because this is some deep stuff but very
quickly my my scene from part one which
I can't wait for people to see and
especially in the Extended Cut is um the
scene in my bed Chambers with the alien
tentacles I know exactly which is not so
deep sure I got I have to stop there um
uh congratulations on the movie I really
do hope it's a huge hit for you guys
thank you for your
time